It is by observing the world around them and having conversations with adults...
...that children learn to communicate.
As caregivers, we are a child's first teachers.
And because having strong speaking and listening skills is key to being an early reader,...
...this makes our job incredibly important.
So what can we do to prepare strong readers?
When having conversations with children, we should ask open-ended questions.
Ones that require more than a yes or no answer.
Listen, wait and observe.
Have patience and give the child time to respond.
Build on what was said or observed.
Repeat, rephrase or expand on the child's response.
These three techniques can be done anywhere at any time.
Let's see some examples.
They have animals with them.
What kind of animals do you see with them?
Yes, there's a monkey, a butterfly.
What else do you see?
What's that?
A fish.
A fish!
You're right.
You want to see the book?
Watch.
Do you like that story?
Sometimes it feels like a one-way conversation.
But notice that by being patient and building on what is observed,...
...the child still participates even if they don't use words.
Very good.
That's a very good circle.
And what else are you going to draw?
What are you gonna do with this circle?
Rayona?
Do you know what you're gonna do with this circle?
You made a bigger circle.
What color is your circle?
That's close, it's purple.